the news from Netherlands is welcome in
the world's largest refugee camp
Zafar Ahmad and his friends gathered
around community ready hearts and tea
stall to hear what is happening at the
international code of justice we would
like to thank Gambia for initiating the
legal process a Bangladesh for giving us
shelter now finally the verdict
recognises our suffering and the
atrocities we feel at peace in our
hearts chiku Farah say she was pregnant
during the Myanmar army clear out
campaign in Rakhine State and knows the
pain of living with trauma and
depression
she runs a woman's advocacy group in the
camp helping others to overcome their
sorrows at the bar they're very happy
after so long finally we get some sort
of justice for years they have sized our
documents and denied us our rights and
citizenship all they have to do now is
reinstate our citizenship and give us
our identity and rights back we also
want to know that we'll be safe the
Bangladeshi government is hoping it gets
more help to cope with caring for the
Rohingya languishing in Bangladesh camps
I rightfully mine
we hope this verdict should make good
sense prevail in Myanmar I'm now hopeful
that Myanmar will take back their people
which they have repeatedly assured us
along with this they also promised that
they will provide them with safety and
security the verdict of the court also
demands the same this verdict is a
victory for the Raheja government
leaders in Myanmar have denied a
genocidal campaign against our ohanga
the unsubstantiated condemnation they
say it presents a distorted picture of
the situation in Rakhine State but for
one of the world's most persecuted
people the ruling has given them a sense
of hope for a better future the legal
process may take years but for the wrong
angle refugees the ruling by the
International Court of Justice is at
least a recognition for their suffering
they regard the ruling as a moral as
well as a psychological victory for
their community sandwhich Audrey al
Jazeera Cox's Bazar Bangladesh